[Music]
so we're back
at playing one minute chess at the
office trying to make it look cool trash
talking a bit
maybe a bit more than we have earlier
i just beat hammer who came out of
retirement
world on the street uh is that he has
retired again
gonna play an actual active chess player
this time the head of streaming didn't
want me to do this
introduction he didn't want to let you
guys know
that this that i'd actually beat him
trying to
pull the video but then i realized i'm
the head of this company so i can make
it happen
and thus it has happened and
once again i'm playing with the fast
talking
rook winning sebastian mihailov and i
was born ready
let's get the game going
[Music]
we got ourselves a benoni and he's
confused already
wow really
what what i don't know what i'm doing
but i can give you pawns i'm not worried
i have contemplated look at this bishop
who would we worried in this situation i
take it
i i give the exchange no worries no
worries i take this part
push it push it baby
he's confused look at him the guy
is completely flustered he has no idea
how to play this position
and my pawns my pawns they are running
they're running indeed
they are running so fast wow look at
this
and i have to be a little bit careful
now uh okay i'll do this i do this
you can you can take it you can take it
i'm winning back material and for the
first time in the game of material
look at this and he's spending so much
time
getting my knight back into the game
tripping over his rook confusing him
that's always good strategy
blundering something not so great but
he's confused he's confused
this is good i blundered but i'm okay
i'm okay it's okay
bishop solid oh he's playing so fast now
[Music]
taking the bishop but is it going to be
fast enough
and it's awesome time another one for me
well that was a mess
i think that was close i was that was
very close just be careful with the
board
and no no reason